on this sunday night getting ready for
the border to reopen
the relief the reluctance and the red
tape it's a huge expense the slow road
back to normal the investigation into a
deadly concert the families of those who
died and everybody affected deserve
answers why weren't safety measures in
place getting hospitals to go green our
single-use dominated supply chain has
created incredible vulnerabilities what
it'll take to overhaul the system and
taxing billionaires
should the ultra wealthy pay a bigger
price
[Music]
global national with robyn gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us in a matter of hours fully vaccinated
canadians will finally be able to drive
to the u.s it's been a long road to get
here nearly two years since the border
closed because of the kova 19 pandemic
but there are still some speed bumps
causing travelers to be cautious about
making a beeline to the border ross lord
has our top story tonight
after the first widespread closure since
the 911 terrorist attacks 20 years ago
getting traffic moving again on both
sides of the canada-us border is a
milestone but moving isn't the same as
moving freely cross-border travel is
still expensive like the canadian
requirement for pcr tests proving
travelers don't have covet 19. the test
can cost up to 300 canadian almost two
years after he and his family were
separated from their travel trailer in
the u.s bc resident rob whittison is not
as excited as he'd like to be bad enough
paying dues for two years and not being
able to use it and now tack on the
cost of the pcr test as well and it's
it's a huge expense
and possibly an obstacle to reopening
border economies many canadians are
already hesitant to mingle with their
american neighbors especially in
communities where masking and distancing
are lacking i still think there's going
to be a great reluctance
by canadians and americans to come on
across the border on mass like they used
to that'll take months and may take
years for that to be recreated the
canadian chamber of commerce says with
the vast majority of travelers double
vaccinated pcr tests are redundant for
that type of traveler it is a
requirement
that you know doesn't need to be in
place canada's top medical authority dr
teresa tam says the pcr test should be
re-examined but others note it's the
best single tool for limiting the spread
of covet 19 through travel the question
is of course how much additional bang
for the buck does it offer that is
unclear the data to my mind is not
is not plentiful it is not convincing
but i think it should remain in place
for the meantime while that data is
collected inching forward on the return
to normal at a price
ross lord global news
disturbing new details are emerging
about the travis scott music festival in
houston texas now one of the deadliest
concert tragedies in u.s history video
shows scott continuing to perform for 37
minutes after police and firefighters
responded eight people died when fans
rushed to the stage the youngest victims
were 14 and 16 years old jennifer
johnson has the latest
flowers candles and cards have been
placed outside houston's nrg center the
site of the travis scott's astroworld
music festival where eight young people
were killed when a crowd of fans surged
toward the stage friday night i'm
honestly just devastated scott one of
music's hottest young stars took to
instagram as reports surfaced the rapper
continued to perform for over half an
hour while first responders were
administering cpr and picking up bodies
videos do show scott at one point
stopping and asking security for help
anytime i can make out
you know anything that's going on you
know you know i'd stop the show and
[Music]
you know help them get the help they
need but it's not the first time there's
been trouble at one of scott's concerts
he pleaded guilty to a misdemeanor in
2015 after fans jumped a security
barricade at a chicago concert and a
second misdemeanor after arkansas police
say he urged fans to rush the stage
during a 2017 concert festival goers say
friday night's event was chaos it was
just going down people were getting
trampled it was just terrible all around
i had my water backpack on and i'm
fortunately
was used to the squishing so i just
thank god i'm alive houston police are
investigating whether people near the
front of the stage were drugged after
reports a security officer was pricked
with a needle he was reaching over to
restrain or grab a citizen and he felt a
prick in his neck
when he was examined he went unconscious
they administered narcan
he was revived live nation the concert
promoter reportedly did not use the pa
system or video boards to broadcast any
safety messages multiple investigations
are underway the families of those who
died and everybody affected deserve
answers and that's why i'm calling for
an objective
independent investigation live nation
provided 755 security officers in
addition to over 520 houston police
officers to handle the sold out crowd of
50 thousand but it wasn't enough to stop
this tragedy
jennifer johnson global news washington
security forces in baghdad are on high
alert following an apparent failed
assassination attempt of iraq's prime
minister mustafa al-khadimi was not hurt
in the attack on his home but a number
of guards were injured canada is among
the countries condemning the attack and
calling for calm in that country mike
trolley reports
the remains of the attack speak to a
devastating explosion that damaged the
home of iraqi prime minister mustafa
al-khadimi it was a modern style
incursion three drones laden with
explosives swooped in on the house two
of which were shot down by security
forces the third wounded six members of
kadimi's protection force
kadimi appeared on camera shortly after
unharmed and resolute
my house was targeted by a cowardly
attack he said the cowardly missiles and
the cowardly drones do not build our
nation and do not build our future
iraq has been caught in political
upheaval since its october elections
were outright rejected by iran-backed
shia militias which have since camped
out in tents near baghdad's green zone
the heavily fortified area that's home
to kadimi's residents as well as iraqi
government offices and international
embassies
kadimi is iraq's former intelligence
chief and is considered to be close to
the u.s he's also tried to ease regional
tensions by hosting talks with saudi
arabia and iran
that combined with his election win led
to protests that turned deadly on friday
between pro-iranian demonstrators and
security forces
those same demonstrators suggested the
attack on the prime minister was a
calculated move by the government itself
they did this to distract people from
what happened friday when they killed
innocent people says this protester
the one thing we do know no group has
claimed responsibility for the attack
leaving tensions dangerously high
mike droli global news toronto
the canadian government is pulling
non-essential staff from its embassy in
ethiopia where there are growing fears a
year-long conflict could spread to the
capital
a huge crowd of government supporters
rallied in addis ababa in a show of
support for the country's military
ethiopian forces are battling rebel
fighters from the northern tigray region
in a war that has already claimed
thousands of lives global affairs canada
says the situation is rapidly devolving
but the embassy will remain open to help
canadians in need of emergency
assistance
later this month merck's copa 19
anti-viral pill will undergo more trials
in the uk all trials so far have been
done with the unvaccinated the next
phase could help researchers understand
how the pill will work in the wider
vaccinated population last week britain
became the first country in the world to
approve the potentially game-changing
pill
medical experts say that vaccines
provide the best protection against
covet-19 canada has one of the highest
rates of inoculation in the world but
there are some communities lagging
behind in toronto there is particular
concern for the indigenous population
kayla mclean reports
unfortunately
if they do catch it they are going to
suffer the worst jonathan wonick
understands intimately the elevated risk
kovit 19 poses to his people the
indigenous leader also understands why
many in his community are reluctant to
take the vaccine there's been a lot of
mistrust to talk a lot of talk about how
the with the government's intentions are
according to a new report only 55
percent of indigenous people over the
age of 15 in toronto have been fully
vaccinated against the virus leaving
roughly 32 thousand people without
protection all this despite the fact
that urban indigenous people were
granted faster access to the vaccines i
think it's tied to the fact that one out
of three first nations inuit met people
living in the city of toronto doesn't
have a regular health care provider and
of those that do there still may be some
gaps in a trusting relationship with
those health care providers dr janet
smiley a metis physician and maine
author behind the report says the
mistrust is deeply rooted in a history
of abuses racism and wrongdoings by the
health care system against indigenous
communities and while the fears are well
founded it's leaving community members
vulnerable
i'm worried that it's going to be a
difficult
winter she predicts with a delta variant
and gradual easing of restrictions 30
thousand partial or in vaccinated
indigenous people could become sick with
the virus between now and may because of
the wear and tear of colonization
that our people are more likely to be
hospitalized and pass away from delta
smiley says to increase vaccine uptake
among indigenous groups vaccine
information needs to be disseminated by
the community for the community when we
have access to community run testing
which we started with good communication
information sharing
and community run vaccination
that can overcome some of those trust
barriers smiley is also calling on the
city to increase indigenous
representation in public health agencies
to boost trust global news reached out
to the city for comment but did not hear
back before broadcast deadline
smiley also encourages indigenous people
who are hesitant towards the vaccine to
reach out to organizations like her own
to answer their questions and address
their anxieties kayla mclean global news
toronto
coming up how to get hospitals to go
green and still provide safe care
and the scary moments over vancouver
international airport that led to a rare
tornado watch
you know
vancouver residents were at the edge of
their seats yesterday when a water spout
hovered near the airport triggering an
ultra rare tornado watch environment
canada's short-lived alert warned of a
potentially life-threatening situation
the storm grazed the university of
british columbia's campus but only
caused minor tree damage and power
outages environment canada says it is
investigating the severe weather
bc and quebec have won international
leadership awards at the cop 26 climate
summit in glasgow the awards came from
the under 2 coalition which is a global
organization of about 260 regions and
states it honored the clean bc program
for most creative climate solutions
aimed at reducing industry emissions and
quebec one for climate partnerships for
its collaborative climate action and
financially supporting climate goals for
regional governments in developing
countries
they're also talking about making health
care greener at cop26 in canada the
medical system contributes to about five
percent of annual emissions that
involves the use of ambulances and
single-use items to change the sector it
would be a massive undertaking and as
jamie morocco explains right now this
country may not be prepared to take it
on
after every canadian surgery tens of
thousands of them each year
all of this becomes garbage says
vancouver surgeon andrea mcneil our
single use dominated supply chain which
has been a fairly wholesale shift in
health care over the last three decades
has created incredible vulnerabilities
and pollution
up to 80 percent of emissions from the
health care system derive from the
supply chain the rest comes from things
such as ambulance rides aging
infrastructure food waste and even from
medications releasing stored up gases
if we want to leave our kids a livable
planet we need to emergently decrease
greenhouse gas emissions the uk's
national health service is well on its
way to its lofty net zero target finding
success by switching to electric
ambulances and less carbon intensive
drugs back in canada some hospitals are
making upgrades where they can at
michael garan in toronto the team
tackled aging hvac and modernized
lighting we are still not there
we have still more work to do
work that costs money ottawa has set
nothing aside to create greener
hospitals that a health ministry
spokesperson says is up to provinces and
territories i do think that part of the
issue with health care is
just how many people that touch it and
the many problems the pandemic has
further complicated hallway medicine
staffing shortages and of course the
treatment backlog burden mcneil prefers
to look at the upside
and the nice thing about the covid
pandemic if i can even call it that is
that it demonstrated to us the agility
of healthcare systems and actually
confirm that when we need to we can
pivot ignorance she says will only
perpetuate climate change and its
negative health effects sending more
patients to hospital in the years ahead
and eventually overwhelming our already
struggling health care system
jamie morocco global news toronto
[Music]
still ahead billing the billionaires the
push for taxing the world ultra wealthy
luck is not on the side of four
astronauts with the spacex mission they
were supposed to wrap up their six-month
mission on the international space
station and return to earth today first
bad weather has delayed their departure
to monday and get this the capsule
they're coming back on has a broken
toilet so they'll have to wear diapers
for their eight-hour journey home
rough ride the cost to launch just one
of those capsules is roughly 55 million
per seat a paltry sum for spacex's
multi-billionaire owner elon musk but as
the world's wealthiest see their
fortunes expand beyond earth they're
still taxed in the u.s at lower rates
than the average person as jackson
proskow reports there's a growing push
for a special wealth tax in a country
that's produced more billionaires than
any other
there's never been a better time to be a
billionaire in america
the ultra wealthy have seen their
fortunes skyrocket
the collective wealth of the top two
elon musk and jeff bezos has risen by
140 billion dollars so far this year yet
they and other billionaires pay no tax
on those gains everybody in this country
that has been blessed and prospered
should pay a patriotic tax that inequity
can be chalked up to the fact that
assets are not considered income until
they're sold billionaires can pay
themselves a relatively small salary and
simply borrow against their immense
wealth on paper to live large and
largely tax-free you might be able to
borrow money from your local bank
and spend that to live a lavish
lifestyle
and enjoy all that increase in the value
of your stock without ever having to pay
tax on that's why some u.s lawmakers are
floating the idea of a billionaire's tax
one that could pay for trillions of
dollars in planned spending the proposal
would target the 700 richest americans
that's anyone with more than one billion
dollars in assets or who makes at least
100 million dollars in annual income i
don't want to punish anyone's success
i'm a capitalist
i want everyone to be able to if they
want to be a millionaire billionaire to
be able to seek their goal
but all i'm asking is
pay your fair share
tesla's elon musk scoffed at the idea
tweeting eventually they run out of
other people's money and then they come
for you
by some estimates musk would owe 50
billion dollars over five years if the
proposal passed i think what it does
address is what many people feel is a
pretty
important unfairness or inequity in the
system there are of course questions
about whether such a specific tax would
be legal or feasible which has left the
proposal on hold for the moment but as
their fortunes continue to grow
america's richest people will all but
certainly face pressure to pay more to
reflect how much wealth they've amassed
jackson prosko global news washington
up next a chance discovery at a thrift
store returns some long lost canadian
honor
take a look at this dozens of colorful
hot air balloons fill the skies of
turkey's ancient cappadocia region this
morning it's one of the country's most
popular tourist destinations and it's
easy to see why the balloons take off
every morning for tourists to catch the
sunrise and glimpses of the unique
volcanic landscape called fairy chimneys
remembrance day will hold a different
meaning to many canadians as we honor
those who paid the ultimate sacrifice
but for one family in winnipeg that day
will now bring extra special
significance thanks to some diligent
detective work in calgary as gil tucker
reports it's all thanks to a chance
discovery in the back of a thrift store
they get all kinds of things coming into
this goodwill donation center in calgary
books clothes um toys
electronics and then one day this past
summer
jonah henderson comes across something
really special i actually just found the
medals canadian forces on it i'm huge
into history so
i thought
this kind of stuff is pretty important
he turns it over to his managers and the
detective work begins
we found the initials j.t and last name
pearson with
just four letters sask we found an
obituary of a john thomas hearson that
he was born in nottingham england and
then had immigrated over to canada and
had settled in waver and saskatchewan we
tracked down
other names from within that obituary we
came across a grandson i didn't really
know that he had the medals so what a
surprise for kelly hearson in winnipeg
it's absolutely wonderful just an
absolute honor to have them and i am
just so thankful to alberta goodwill for
reaching out for taking the time and
making the effort to find me it was just
fantastic like to know we found a family
member it's a really heartwarming
feeling medal's j.t herson won for his
service in both world wars we will look
after them
have them displayed prominently with the
others that i have i have medals from my
father and also from three uncles we are
pretty blessed and it was their
sacrifices which got us where we are
jonah is also grateful for his family's
service my great grandfather
i actually he fought in world war ii
and
i actually have all of his paperwork
from world war ii and he's glad to have
played a part in getting these medals
back where they belong very very uh
satisfying it's a joyful thing bill
tucker global news
that's a great story and that is global
national for this sunday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the sun rising
over bird river in manitoba there are so
many beautiful spots all over canada so
please keep sending your pictures to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen is
back tomorrow have a great night
[Music]